[Music]
the sound of severe donetsk being
pounded and broken by bombs never stops
[Music]
ukrainian troops vastly outnumbered here
can see the russians blasting their way
in
and underneath all these explosions
there are civilians still trying to
survive
the situation's becoming increasingly
dire at this point
one of the main bridges linking the city
to the rest of the donbass has already
been bombed and is now impossible
so when we enter it's by the only route
left the last usable bridge which has
also been hit several times
it's the city's remaining lifeline and
on our arrival the ukrainians are only
just holding on to it
inside we see an humanitarian disaster
rapidly unfolding with thousands of
people still here
this is a city which russia would have
banked on being pro kremlin with strong
links and often with relatives living
there they are very reluctant to
evacuees but they are fleeing in the
face of this terrible onslaught
it's a hell you know it's hell uh
first
uh everyday
second a lot of death
third humanitarian uh problems
the seoul working hospital is now
surrounded by russian troops so the only
chance for the injured is to be
evacuated and this is one of the very
few evacuation trips
now it seems like the front is all
around the city it's practically
surrounded their tanks they are like
we can see
trucks from the army being being
deployed around the city so it seems
very clear that to me
uh it's about to fall are you glad to be
going
yes and no
i don't know
feeling sad about leaving as well
but time is running out of there to
leave
and these volunteers hope to be back
later to help more flee
a handful are delivering water strapping
bottles on the back of their bikes to
take to those trapped in their homes
he was a musician once
now his world is filled with the sounds
of war
a small moment to collect himself
but we will win he tells us
everything will be okay
valerie's another it's far away he
reassures us about the bombing the
strength of these people continues to
astonish
we're used to it he says it's been three
months
valeria and his wife neela won't leave
they've notched up 135 years between
them and they're now enduring bombs
which are landing every few minutes
it is unrelenting and goes on and on as
he weaves his way back through his
community and takes us to his home where
he and his neighbors have been
sheltering and where he's been ferrying
food and water to
where there seems to be still a fair
amount of people living
his neighbors tell us how hard it is to
get even water
yelena's saying she has to carry two or
three bottles by hand
everyone begins to panic at what sounds
like cluster bombs landing far too close
by we head for the doorway to shelter
open the basement for larry shouts come
come he says i'm used to it everyone
piles inside waiting for yet more
incoming bombs
every day is like this elena tells us it
was quiet for just 10 minutes
every day it's back and forth like this
flying over our heads
seconds later valeria's punched by a
neighbor he's angry at valeri for
bringing foreign journalists here
many blame us for prompting the bombings
this war has set pensioner against
pensioner and forced neighbours to turn
on each other
i'm trying not to cry she says i'm
trying to keep myself calm but you need
to tell them what the situation is
this is going on all the time
constant barrage it's unbelievable that
there are so many people
who are still living and having to put
up with this
they're right in the middle of it
at the aid hub more injured have been
brought in and one woman has got a very
nasty head wound there's no gunshot
wound it's just a shrapnel
the worst injuries to her head but she
just needs to get evacuated for that
it turns out sky news colleague nick
davenport is the most qualified medic
here probably in the whole of the city
there's a police trained first aider too
who asked not to be identified
there are two badly wounded here but
most certainly not the only ones in dire
need of medical help in the city
emma is back with her evac team but her
vehicle has broken down so she's
urgently trying to find replacements
we only have two
passenger vehicles
somehow the aid hub manager finds a way
out for them
this is going to be a difficult and
dangerous journey for them
but at least they have hope
there's very little of that going around
this city right now as we can hear the
russian troops getting nearer and the
military circle around several donetsk
closing in
a lot of people with no option have
hunkered down in an old soviet-built
bunker day and night
they cook food on fires in the open
power and running water stopped weeks
ago but it's always done within easy
reach of their underground shelter
to descend down here is to enter a truly
grim dank and perpetually dark place
desperation and despair stalk the
concrete corridors and disease runs riot
there's a shame here amongst the
residents a real embarrassment about
being reduced to this
there are nearly a hundred people living
on top of one another twenty feet
underground the only place they feel
offers them some chance of survival from
the bombings above
they've had an outbreak of tuberculosis
people have caught pneumonia in here
hygiene's obviously extremely hard in
these terribly cramped conditions and we
hear constant coughing and wretching
sheets of cardboard are used as
separation but they offer scant privacy
and all this is all they have salvaged
from their lives
life has a post-apocalyptic feel about
it down here but still some display a
steely determination to come through
this
[Music]
i must
survive i don't think about those
challenges bombings explosions and so on
and so forth i just wanna i just
have to or even musk
must survive
there's a half hour when the generators
switched on and they have power there's
a rush to charge phones used for light
and to take the chance to maintain some
self-care
but it also means they can pump water
and stock up on supplies
tanya goes round the shelter telling
everyone this is the final opportunity
to get out of several dinettes
this is the last chance for evacuation
she says think about it
but no one here is ready to flee their
home city despite the obvious dangers
many here have had access only to
russian propaganda and believe they're
liberating them
we sleep in a warehouse the police tell
us to be ready to head out in the middle
of the night should the russian troops
move into the city no one expects it to
be long
by dawn there are already people
gathered hoping they can get a ride out
to safer ground
they've woken to more intense bombing
russian troops are at the city gates and
the noose is tightening
this has been going on
this has been going on all morning
there are lots and lots of residents
still living here a lot of them old
people and having to run in and out of
this just to cook or to fetch water it
is relentless
the russians are bombing street by
street in their efforts to capture this
city blasting houses and homes which
stand in their path they have the
momentum now
and the destruction is immense
taking sevra donetsk would mean the
whole of the lehansk region falls to
russian control
maria and ivan have lived here all their
married lives now they're outdoor
kitchens amongst the world's most
dangerous
they've just got food scraps and blame
both sides for targeting civilians
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on come on says maria this is so
hard for the elderly who don't
understand why there's a war over
donbass at all
maria urges ivan to clear space for us
to shelter they're more worried about
our safety
this is what their days are like now
dodging explosions and separated from
their grandchildren
[Music]
and they feel they've been badly let
down by their city leaders
[Music]
so far they've been lucky but they've
come close
but the real hurt is in the family
separation
the city already looks smashed to pieces
but there are thousands of civilians
still inside and the russians show no
signs of stopping their barrage yet
alex crawford sky news inside sevra
donetsk in the donbass eastern ukraine